bonjour bienvenue sûreté bonal tv avec
jean baptiste stéphane alors aujourd'hui
jean baptiste on va faire un petit tour
sur la variante française pour une
variante que tu donnes tu va nous dire
maintenant qu un peu technique
alors là mccutchen mccutchen mccutchen
wallace en écosse à ilan écossais alors
12 d'où vient le nom ça je ne peux pas
te dire exactement ce qu'il va manquer à
ses anciennes aussi
comme toutes les variantes de française
puisque c'est une ouverture qui a joué
depuis
depuis très très longtemps voilà donc on
va voir qu'à une petite nuance par
rapport à l'avant steinitz et le
développement du foot case noire avant
de pousser le centre alors on va voir ça
tout de suite c'est la surenchère dans
le groupe contrôle du centre alors à
près de 4 le 6 voilà des cadres des
quatre ans du club des cinq cavaliers c3
pour maintenir l'attention
on avait parlé de cavaliers f6 alors il
ya d'autres le sont on parle d'eux la
1ère heure vina works iw le couffo b4
classique on coule qu'elle a gagné
l'autre variantes connues
c'est là steinitz avec cavaliers f6
voilà les blancs après joue le coup eux
quatre scènes mais il ya une autre
option voile arabes envers lui dans la
vente et nice les blancs se décide à
jouer du couple simple pour profiter de
la sortie du cavalier ici ils ont pas
encore abdiqué ils veulent garder
l'attention et il joue plutôt le
courroux g5 trouvaient cinq arrêts
clouage voilà
youku g5 qui rend inopérante la sortie
du cavalier et puis avec une menace
quand même
c'est de jouer le pion aux 5es aussi
bien la menace principale c'est bien sûr
d'exploiter le clouage et donc de jouer
le 5
alors pour parer cette menace c'est bien
on a on a plusieurs possibilités soit on
se décline en jouant fouet cette fois
cette possibilité il ya plus de trois
mois soit on va encore plus loin dans la
surenchère et on joue au foot et 4 qui
écailles la variante mccutchen qui
contrôle à son voile à 1 contre cloud
âge
en fait et donc on va espérer exercer le
même type de pression que celle que les
blancs ont réalisé sur cavalli m6 alors
laquelle on regarde on peut commencer
par x 7
alors il faut entre guillemets la plus
normale en ce sont ceux des clous alors
là maintenant que le cavalier donc est
plus floue et il faut que les blancs se
décide et j'ouvre le coût de 5
oui parce que là la menace des noirs
c'est de prendre quatre oui maintenant
se prononce comme à l'écran un cadre
d'accueil provoqua des simply fait la
position rapidement
voilà aussi un grand gagnant a pu rompre
au passage taguant pas forcément facile
à reprendre alors au cinq cas relief 17
voilà donc là en fait on se retrouve
dans une position très similaires avance
tennis sauf que on a la possibilité d'un
échange de fou alors deux possibilités
maintenant soit on réalise les changes
nous aime soit on incite les noirs à le
faire eux mêmes alors ya pas 36 manières
pour laisser le fou angers 5 puisqu'il
attaqué deux fois et protégé 0 leur
correspond à faire pour laisser le
fourrage est simple et bien on peut
jouer le coup h 4 alors ça c'est violent
ça parce qu'alors on donne un pion h
théâtre en donne un pion mais on voit
quand même tout de suite
clairement la compensation des blancs
c'est la colonne h ouverte alors la tour
ici évidemment sera ouverte ici sur
cette colonne on a tout à fait donc la
tour elle va elle va faire une action
assez importante sur la colonne âge
d'autre part c'est aussi le mauvais
placement de la dame une fois qu'elle
aura repris le pion angers 5 on assoit
h4 soit on fait les changes nous mêmes
en eux cette voie là soit donc l'autre
coup on la comprend et sait ou croit
cette nouvelle ample robe d'abord par
les fous procède donc d'un projet 7 lors
d'un ce cas-là d'emprunter cette voie là
ici on va encore prendre les devants
parce qu'on sait que les noirs vont
jouer ces cinq beaucoup tard les noirs
vont jouer ces 5
donc on joue le coup à f4 et classique à
la française qu'on va retrouver dans la
française consolide de santé un coup
prophylactique
on sait que d'autres furent des quatre
est amené à disparaître alors toujours
double 1 terrasse cour ou surprotège
desseigne mais aussi on prépare une
éventuelle poussée f5 plus tard voilà
quand le centre sera stabilisée hélas
les noirs doivent jouer le coup à six et
terminèrent voix à vendre ces cinq là
parce que si on avait joué ses cinq tout
de suite on aurait eu un débarquement de
cavaliers très désagréable avec le
cavalier b5 et menaces qu'elle aimait
sièges seulement de gagner la tour par
carrie c7 que ça fasse fourchette ou non
je dirais oui parce que même sur petit
rorqual et c'est diane la tour est aussi
et aussi si le roi reste l'alpha
cavaliers deux des six est donc
d'installer un cavalier sur une case
très importante de cette position qui la
classe des 620 cavale xr énorme d613 des
clous et on peut imaginer le coup
cavaliers à 6 pour les noirs qui voient
la main des moindre mal et dans ce cas
là car les des six le roi et des clous
et le cas validé si c'est énorme énorme
avantage dans le terreau qui le roi et
des rockets et les cavaliers et très
bien installés alors donc sur les
frégates ça explique le coup assise là
le coup ainsi qu'une perte de temps dans
les bars où seraient bien passés mais
cavaliers f3 on continue de vêtements
ces cinq banques n'en valent maintenant
c5 est possible voilà dam des deux parce
qu'on veut toujours faire grand robe de
position puisque on va attaquer sur
l'aileron fonctions aux places la dame
quand même sur une case adéquat pour
pouvoir préparer le rock cavaliers ses
six gros rock voilà et la battant bon on
est à un carrefour t variantes mais on
peut par exemple que montrer que si les
noirs je le pousse c4 c4 avec l'idée de
dix rebelles mènent maintenant que le
roi maintenant que j'ai une information
sur la place du roi effectivement je
peux commencer mon attaque sur les dames
qui toussait et cassel a essayé de
monter une attaque 1 voilà es-tu en
parlais tout à l'heure quand le centre
est fermé et bien on a les mains libres
maintenant pour réaliser notre poussée
avec les blancs qui est la poussée f5 et
voilà un fait si les blancs qui prenais
devant tout de suite
alors maintenant leurs protégés qui ont
des quatre protège très bien aussi
lui-même n'est plus attaquer donc on
peut jouer le poète 50
voilà le plus récente est pas protégé
mais évidemment le calice et trois sur
un contre jeu sur le club des cinq
on se serait vraiment une très mauvaise
affaire pour les noirs de venir doubler
son pur au f pour laisser le pire des
cinq centrales qui est une
importante un peu plus qu'à l'idée 5
aurait des grosses menaces comme tu le
montre très bien avec les flèches ouais
voilà donc ça c'est sûr c'est plutôt sur
la variante avec faut prendre cette
cruelle et blanc et changement est sûr
partie agréable
il faut quand même mentionné que le coup
c'est 4 n'est pas forcément le meilleur
on a une partie si les noirs ici
continue par exemple par le coût des
sept baies san qui paraît logique
eh bien on peut continuer par exemple
il faudrait mettre la pression
supplémentaire sur les droits alors là
c'est vrai qu'on va avoir un problème
sur notre aile dame si on regarde la
position en l'état donc on peut
peut-être déplacer la dame pour
continuer la pression peut-être ailleurs
f4 par exemple sur le masque voilà ici
on va continuer là la pression
et puis en plus le faire il pourra tout
droit sur beckett il faudra bouger le
cavalier puis j'ai eu 4 on a
suffisamment de pièces quand même pour
défendre les dames
non mais bon là pour est parti quand
même ce qui devrait encore une part
d'ombré
avec quand même pour les blancs un plan
clair c'est de jouer sur la colonne f1
voila voila on pourrait devoir essayer
de créer du contre joël dame sachant
qu'ils ont du mal puisqu'ils sont quand
même fou qui est qui le movie feront
donc et si ils font le petit rond qu'on
voit que déjà la taxe des blancs est
tellement avancée que ça paraît
extrêmement voilà attendre l'homme c'est
le roi noir aussi la porte ou et d'abris
c'est donc
donc ça c'est surtout prendre 7 mai
encore plus intéressant ce pire est
atteint c'est la vie on ne soigne on
n'est pas obligé d'avoir tous le même
avis c'est de granby aller qu'initiateur
donc développé par hal eakin donc au
début du 20 siècle et au début du 20e
siècle assure est remis à la mode par
l'éternel garry kasparov qui a qui a
fait de ce grand bi sont dans le
principal contre la défense française
c'est le coût ashkan ashkan donc ça on a
déjà parlé un petit peu
alors il y a deux façons de réagir comme
toujours un gros billet soit le refuse
soit on accepte alors si et les noirs le
refuse
ils ont des possibilités qui sont quand
même assez limité quand même pour
le refuser il ya le coup à six il ya le
coup c'est ça aussi qui est une faute
qui est pas terrible parce qu'on avait
vu toute attaque à vendre et c'est ça
qu'il valait mieux jouer à 6 alors on
peut jouer il faut prendre cette ici et
tout de suite
ensuite avoir envie d'installer ce
cavalier prend b5 donc là l'idée d'un
autre parti de référence qui est une
parti entre morrow et beach avec les
blancs et quand ce toy c'est que quand
nous y penser que le son roi en scène
serait pas plus à placer qu'autre chose
87 il y joue mais en fait il est quand
même mal placé il est quand même assez
mal placé
en tout cas la pression du du roi sur la
case des six empêche un petit peu le
plan cavaliers bessin cavaliers des six
parce qu il y aurait un moyen de
supprimer éventuellement le pion de 5
pour pouvoir une fois que le cavalier
temps des six le prendre mais on va
changer de plan maintenant que le roi
étant le set on va voir comment morose
et vite ch développe son attaque contre
le roi au centre mais ça se mangeront
tout simplement jean françaix 5 il va
sortir ces pièces vers le centre finale
développement et compter sur la
faiblesse chronique du roi qui traînent
toute façon en recettes ce qui peut pas
trouver des abris sûrs dames c'est cette
f4 dame français 5 voilà d'hommes d2
pour l'instant avec la partie
tranquillement aux normales et jean
claude le roy est au centre c'est vrai
que on s'est refusée par se voir ça pour
avoir ce qu'alice existe c'est rosie f3
cavalli b6 pour donner un peu d'air au
four à placer le cavalier voilà à 3,5
alors une manoeuvre intéressante aussi
qu'il faudrait retenir c'est le coup à
chaque âge 5 voilà pourquoi c'est tout
parce qu'on veut s'en prendre comme dans
la weed avoir purgé 7 qui n'a plus de le
défenseur après le départ du foie fuite
voilà donc on va super bien sûr pour
saatchi et tourache trois tours g3 aussi
qui est un autre thème surtout est à
l'orage 300 g iii avec pression soutien
à chis six grands rock food et c3 b1
vous voyez que c'est tout à fait
tranquille à 4 tours h3 maintenant
entourage 3 voilà ça y est la casse
bessette montre sa faiblesse voilà on
dirait que les deux camps développe
georges
tranquillement tour ses huit cavaliers
b5 à cavaliers qui arrive parce que la
tour et ans et 8 maintenant donc les
savoisiens est assuré de gagner à temps
il a attendu que tour ses huit tranches
des mythes
c'est pas de la théorie comme ont tracé
une partie largo d'elle pour montrer un
mais sur quelle voie les six tombes et 8
vous voyez donc toujours cette faiblesse
évidemment une fois que les footeux
quasiment son échange comme si le pion
ses 7 juin c'est simple c'est évidemment
de ces faits mais sur quinze morts dont
il faut profiter à la moindre
possibilité torje 3 voilà la belle a le
purger sept et attaquer et donc core
tier 1 à 0 et fuite film est sûr et
après dun des trois mètres et bien tout
simplement parce que il ya des menaces
conforte enfin la nasa parable tout
simplement jouer le damage tête et on
peut plus protéger cette es6 et noir
jouent le coup c'est un peu roi g8
alors là et bien tout simplement car à
l'épaule et rama tic puisque ont fait
cavaliers pro f 7 pour attirer le roi
sur la case f7 si on reprend et bien là
sur le crois que ce serait ma force et
après deux jeux 6 échecs fuite l'homme
prend g7 on voit que c'est matt rapide
il suffit de voir la jouer quelques
coups on voit qu'il ya dedans mais j'ai
dit à ma cheville de celui de tours g7
matin tout simplement euros ouais voilà
prêt roy e miz alors peut-être pas au g8
met en rage suite à je suis tour eiffel
était de retour de la d'avant et puis la
sidam et fuite mais tout simplement même
tour g8 tout simplement un permis gagne
la dame c'est pas m en tout cas la
partie sacrifie donc revenir sur granby
chatard h41 alors sur ashdod
on a vu ces 5 où on a parlé de 1,6 il
faut voir le l'envi petit rock est
possible aussi mais le plus intéressant
quand même c'est de comprendre pour
presque gambie est bon qu'on va regarder
l'acceptation avec vos projets sont les
prochaines manches et 5 et là d'un
projet 5 sinon on aurai je dirais les
inconvénients sans en avoir les
avantages un sujet de prendre le pion
sur voilà et maintenant alors eux
les blancs ont essayé au cours des
années plusieurs plans mais le plan de
kasparov
ces dames détroit voilà cook a été
employé ensuite bien des reprises
pourquoi parce qu'on a une menace
directe sur le pion achètent
oui la menace tout simplement c'est de
faire tourner en âge c est tout
simplement et on a développé la dame
ouais alors pour défendre nos deux pions
et bien on peut parler par exemple du
coup j'ai six fait pacifique qui fait
jamais plaisir à jouer mais j'avais
plaisir est là le plan est très simple
en fait on joue cavalier f3 ouais
et s'il cran la dame repart en dix huit
médias ou en visitant des huit comédiens
mythe de la porte je dirais eh bien on
va essayer de récupérer d'autres pions
avec turaci en bloc
voilà on bloque en bloc le pion à vii et
on va faire tout simplement grand roque
ont amené la deuxième tour en un chien
voilà avec une pression énorme et on va
récupérer le pion avec un gros bénéfices
c'est l'affaiblissement total de
l'aileron la case f7 sera très faible
avec cette voie là toutes les pièces
d'or ont disparu de l'aileron il reste
une pièce et l'euro bien sûr c'est un
gros problème bien sûr et on voit que
toutes les pièces noires sont entassés
sur la halle dames et servent pas à
grand chose
bien sûr voilà donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle les noirs doivent éviter quand
même des coups comme g6 et ils vont
essayer au contraire de réaliser une
contre attaque avec cavaliers c6 alors
qu'à nécessite donc l'idée là c'est que
si on prend en effet sept îles sans âge
7 ici on se venge sur le plan des 4
voilà en gros c'est ça c'est vraiment
elle a noté que la dame g5 ici quand
même pour l'instant empêche aussi le
rock voilà c'est important et donc les
blancs doivent d'abord joué le coup car
les trois points donc on a parlé
simple efficace pour déloger
la dame il protège le tour des quatre
osier il protège aussi tourné qu'à
blessures très essentiel voilà prêt
permettra de récupérer le pion alors
l'idée des noirs ici c'est de jouer
d'alger six dames les six proposés
change de dames
voilà est pour l'instant sous le pire en
tout cas sur le coeur et la dame projet
six dames prochain s'il a des bras l'idf
projet sif arrière on prend des pions f
mais ça alors on éloigne un pion du
centre maison donc on affaiblit puis on
aurait signé tout de suite
tout simplement et là le fameux coup le
coup qu'on a envie de jouer parce qu'il
ya durant ces 7 qui traîne donc à
réaliser cinq fois la coupe classique du
truc alors le pion est toujours ans et
c'est donc qui contrôle la case et si ça
c'est un plus
par contre tout de suite il n'y a pas de
moyen de défendre alors si il y aurait
rhodésienne des huit qui est super
faible
rodez 8 et maintenant on fait la taille
de l'autre côté avec i'm sorry avec avec
trois des huit par ce roi des huit ils
iront fairtec de l'autre côté avec
cabanisation qu'il est menacé de
fourchette de porte ou menace car il
prend les progressistes suis vite car il
prend ses cernes voir c'est la vallée
seine et le pion à steinbourg watch ces
ghettos qui en est en tout cas en l'air
voilà donc ça c'est pas bon donc les
noirs sont obligés d'admettre qu'ils
vont perdre ce pion est ce qu'il ya des
médecins qui devait être fait pour est
nécessaire crochète déjà les blancs ont
réussi leur coupe aux ruines on va se
servir avec les blancs quel point ces
sept
alors on voit que les blancs réussi à la
fois à casser cette structure ici qui
est éloigné couper ici et en prendre un
pion ses sept îles ont isolé trois îlots
pions en main trois îlots contre un seul
îlot pour les blancs donc déjà puisque
les blanches les pions blancs peuvent
tous se protéger éventuellement les uns
les autres
alors que là il ya trois cibles du côté
noir donc déjà gros avantage
positionnelle tout de suite la courbe
est vite retombé vite alors l'attention
les doigts au tout petit nas et de
coincer le cavalier classique un élément
à 6,5 à elle ne peut plus sortir ni là
ni là ni en d5 né en russie ce donc la
menace c'est de jouer des coups comme
par exemple carlier fuite suivi de 3,17
et le cavalier perdu donc il faut le
sortir avant que le mal d'arriver on
joue cavalier b5
mais là on n'est pas obligés de regarder
matin jusqu'au bout la position est
quand même très intéressante bien sûr on
a ici quand il disait un avantage de
structure avec un seuil aurait pu
rentrer trois fossés vite très mauvais
sur un cavalier indécise qui valait sur
une très intéressante et notre jeu avec
les blancs ça va être attaqué sur les
droits en faisant grand rock food et 3
et on attaquera le long des colonnades
fou des trois vies si le foot dans celui
de la menace tout de suite frange ici ce
qui va tomber si les noirs jouent à 6
c'est la cage et si ce qui est faible
voilà c'est assez difficile à jouer
quand même du côté noir est tellement
facile à jouer du côté blanc on va jouer
le coup c2 c3 aussi pour consolider sa
chaîne nos pions la casse des six aussi
qu est une horreur voilà enfin on
tellement davantage que les noirs ne
peuvent que subir
voilà alors évidemment on peut penser
que les noirs n'ont pas bien joué c'est
le cas mais il faut savoir que dans
cette partie de kasparov s'est quand
même corps selon un cabinet noir donc un
éminent spécialisé la défense française
double vice champion du monde encore
qu'un camp exact c'est pour vous montrer
quand même que cette ouverture avec les
blancs a beaucoup de bonheur et donc
c'est une norme que l'on vous conseille
tout à fait alors sauf ou g5
on n'est pas obligé donc de protéger le
clouage parfois 7
on avait aussi parlé de la contre
attaque mccutchen avec fougue et 4 x 4
voilà donc mccutcheon
alors c'est un coup intéressant lors on
joue que cinq ont joué aux siens qui
l'idée de base est oui et peut-être
qu'on comprend pas tout de suite
d'ailleurs ce que veulent faire les noix
pour contre attaquer eh bien il joue à
chis classique quand on se prend ce type
prise encourage le problème du fou c'est
que si bien h4 on peut quand même joué
g5 et donc le desclaux âge se fait
naturellement tout à fait voilà donc le
clonage
il peut être grave quand même parce
qu'on peut qu'on peut avoir une
structure de pions très démoli à la
suite mais n'est pas forcément synonyme
de perte de pièces non mais d'autant
plus qu'en fait on échangerait un
cavalier contre le fou de cases noires
et notre fougueusement deviendrait très
fort donc ce ne serait pas forcément une
bonne affaire de jouer fou h4 on préfère
en fait jouer le retrait du fou alors là
tout a été essayé
oui fou c'est un fou des deux est fou et
3 alors donc on va regarder peut-être le
alors la ligne principale c'est fou nous
c'est fou d2f ou des deux camps logique
puisqu'on des clous le cannabis et voilà
donc sur food et de bien il faut bâton
bouger le cavalier cavalli donc il faut
bouger en quatre
évidemment on peut pas le faire tout de
suite parce que s'ils ont joué cavalier
ou quatre pour les noirs les noirs
wheeler cavalier est attaquée faut pas
oublier à lui sur l'idée c'est de le
bouger un cadre mais là il y aurait qu à
l'alien cavaliers viennent y aurait une
pièce puisque sur fou prend ses fans
comprendront cavalli prend voilà
cavaliers prandelli au passage en a pris
une pièce souvent les débutants oublie
ça oui c'est un petit figures
géométriques que même pas forcément les
débutants oublie même les bons choix
même des joueurs de clubs confirmés ou à
lui cette petite astuce tactique souvent
l'affairé contre les pièges et je
comprends pas il me manque une ligne
pourtant nationaux ce qui s'est en fait
ils expliquent ils en ont repris qu'une
et pas deux événements beaucoup des deux
doigts qu'il faut donc supprimer ce
cavalier c'est 3% comprend donc l'idée
tout est logique donc on revient aussi
asseoir le cavalier sur la case de 4
voilà il faut prendre ces trois donc là
on reprend du pied alors assez classique
parce que le fou en c3 savait très très
mal placé il a pas d'avenir et après
cavaliers 1 4 il serait menacée de
toutes façons d'être pris donc le coût
dépensé 3 est logique mais nous
reviennent le centre voilà après faut
penser trois ils pourraient prix en c3
et avant l'affaiblissement de structure
sans pour autant garder le podcast ward
ainsi autant le prendre tout de suite
avec le pion c3 même si ça peut paraître
un petit peu étrange
de prime abord c'est clair cavalier ou 4
alors là car on profite encore de la
disparition du fou de ghazoua pour jouer
dans le g4 coup classique voilà de la
française dams et 4 j'attaque toujours
fermeture g7 extrêmement classique
également choisi ce le coup j'étais sûr
possibilité g6 et la ligne principale
alors là on va se développer
tranquillement avec foot est roi alors
là on a moins peur d'affaiblir les cases
moi parce qu'en fait le cabrio 4 peut
prendre le fou en fait voilà on est
moins qui est un fait rien en foot est
roi
la foulée trois balles donc la question
est posée maintenant on est obligé de
céder le cavalier bien placé au centre
contre caen 1-2 foot gaze noire qui est
une pièce qui nous inquiétait un petit
peu mais sur roy prend des deux alors ça
peut paraître surprenant que le roi
reste aussi comme ça mais là le sentais
bien fermé donc on sera pas grand chose
oui souvent dans la française on n'a pas
peur vraiment d assez souvent
oui consignes du moment que sont très
faibles oui avec ses structures dans ce
dossier trois des quatre cinq donc le
plan pour les morts les compris c'est
d'ouvrir le centre dame cet essai est
maintenant on va exercer notre action
sur les droits avec lâche 4 je vois là
on n'a que des cookies ceux qui se
recoupent dans toutes ses variantes de
france est ce vraiment est bien sûr
toujours la tour qui protège la manche
du pion toujours classique toujours les
mêmes idées
d'où l'intérêt de bien connaître les
idées générales d'une ouverture puisque
de même d'une variante à l'autre on va
retrouver des idées avait des ordres de
tous différents souvent qui balance une
cavale et 17
donc là l'idée qu'avec 17 évidemment ces
deux tableaux qu'ils font ces sept jours
et 17 sur ces scènes qui est de pouvoir
reprendre avec lecavalier
voilà autant le cuir au sol de prendre
le pion 5 bien sûr aussi
les blancs dont sans doute protégé avec
le coup f4 évidemment pour protéger le
saigne toujours des coupes classiques
oui c'est un coup double usage on
protège le tueur le 5 et puis en même
temps au contrôle la danse dû purger
cinq parce qu'on a toujours en tête
évidemment cette idée de pousser le pur
h4 soit cadeau à chaque c'est pour
casser 12 à tour j'évite donc là qu'on
évite la poussée h5 puisqu'on ont créé
un vis-à-vis intéressant oui parce que
vous sachiez maintenant menacée puisque
f pranger 5e a été possible pour les
blancs donc ouais
cabaye f3 logique donc on a plus qu'à la
fin on contrôle encore la cage des
femmes le coup thématique des noirs c5
est là à chaque parce qu on a bien
compris maintenant la cage et 5 cm / g 5
coffrets pu engranger 5 puis on prend et
hi5
c'est là le concours le pion cours et va
immobiliser des pièces adverse
toujours extrêmement classique c'est
l'heure pour ces quatre estiment les
blancs des noirs pardon faut 2 donc
l'algérie avait trop de trop de pression
sur le plongé de 6,3 de questions sur le
thon g 6e pas trop le choix
le 2.2 et damas trois donc laure damas
trois coups aussi thématiques en bloc le
pian le pion à 2 sinon peut-être les
blancs rejouer à 4 et en profite pour
venir chatouiller voilà le vrai tueur
n'est de faire une petit château il a
vécu cavaliers b6 cavaliers à claques
mais s'il qualiac a peut-être même du b5
b4 et des draps 5 éventuellement fait
voilà on essaie de s'en prendre quand
même le roi des deux qui pour l'instant
est à l'abri mais pourrait ne pas l'être
c'est la faiblesse du côté blanc c'est
le principal inconvénient pas facile à
attaquer mais il faut le faire alors je
prends g6 bons tours angers 6 évidemment
qu'à spa sa structure de pions et on
protège pions en chine
oui on protège le rachis surtout dommage
3 donc ça c'est un petit inconvénient
j'ai trop poussé la dame mais on va se
venger après avec la position de la tour
j'ai six dont cavaliers b6 on en a parlé
g4g 4 alors à noter aussi que la maj 3
un petit oeil sur le client de lancer
trop important voilà c'est un quand même
temps ce latéral un jeu positionnelle
très impressionnant de la part des
blancs en l'occurrence de petter l'écho
dans cette partie contre morose et vici
fou 17 ou de cette fois-ci mg5 mélanger
c'est donc parce que si le pion âge
prendre ses fans on peut peut-être alors
s'il y en a je prendrais on aurait
éventuellement une descente de l'adav
ensuite qui serait intéressante
ou alors qu'avant les professeurs car
les projets c'est tout simplement qu'ils
menacent aussi obsède par exemple des
coûts quoi d'amsterdam achète voire des
coups comme damage suite maintenant ça
va je suis encore plus fort ce qui
pourrait y avoir des carénages cet échec
est rien en faire une chose comme ça
donc il faut faire attention
voilà donc sûr j'ai cinq cavaliers à 4
pour attaquer le pion la menace elle est
noire qui menace depuis trois ans et
prend attention avec une potentialité en
défend avec un coût qui attaquent
cavaliers h4 kailash 4 alors double idée
un chat un chat au rachis et je protège
in extremis le pion ses trente ans qu'on
voit que la dame est quand même très
très bien placé voilà donc la fait bien
la différence entre la théorie que vous
devez connaître le petit bagage
nécessaire pour jouer et une partie
illustratif j'irai on est plutôt dans la
partie il sera bien sûr mais on voit
quand même clairement quelles leçons le
plan des bleus le plan des droits après
tour g8 d'ailleurs et puis on prend 1,6
ça y est on peut dire qu'elle en soit et
cravates sont quand même très bien
puisque la le pion à 6 h 7 savait très
très difficile à défendre pour les noirs
voilà donc on a en fait on a montré sa
vente mccutchen avec juste la variante
foulée deux variantes poussé info 3
ressemble un petit peu avec des petites
nuances tactiques en plus il ya plus de
granby disons on protège pas directement
kawaï et c3 on est prêt même à donner un
pion pourra conserver le [ __ ] cases
noires avec les blancs dont c'est la
principale différence ici on entre la
ligne principale avec food et 2 donc
dans cette sont stéphane deux choses on
se déclare fouet cette sur fuji simple
ou alors on joue la contre attaque
mccutchen voilà contre le coup fouet cet
or vous conseille le grand bialecki
chatr très intéressant beaucoup
d'initiatives et contre l'as mccutcheon
on développe tous notre jeu habituel sur
les droits donc un conseiller sur cette
défense cavaliers six coups fourrés sa
cavale avait d'ailleurs sur flu g5 on
verra dans une autre leçon la faveur des
grands maîtres va plutôt on peut
regarder et donner peut-être l'eau à la
bouche non pas sur fouquet 4 ou fawcett
qui sont considérés comme des variantes
un peu passive et sur des preuves 4 qui
passait pendant très longtemps pour une
variante assez plate c'est vrai qu'elle
l'est maintenant qui est beaucoup plus
solide et beaucoup moins passive que la
main en fou et 7 par exemple des pro 4
la variante rubinstein
on verra ça dans une autre mais voilà
les merci de nous avoir suivi sur cette
leçon puis on vous dit à une prochaine
pour étudier encore les variantes
techniques qu'il faut connaître pour
battre ses camarades de club et leur
montrer qu'on est plus fort et les
autres après les autres aussi bien sûr à
bientôt un manteau m